翻訳: Koichiro Yoda
校正: Shoko Takaki
（英語）皆さん こんばんは
（英語）私は若宮正子で 80歳です
（英語）今日は 皆さんに
私のお話をします
（英語）心の中に
自分の木を 育みましょう
あなたは あなたの心の中に
何本の木を持っていますか？
私は
インターネットの木
旅行の木、ピアノの木
それから「エクセルアート」という
Excelでデザインをする木
それから 感動の木
その他 たくさんの木を
持っていますけれども
今日は その中から「英語の木」について
お話をさせていただきます
私がここで「木」と言っているのは
私の心の中に ちょっと芽生えている
小さな種 — 胚芽ですね
これを 私が育てて
だんだん大きくして
そのうちに 葉が茂り 実がなって
大きな木になる
それに対する
というんでしょうかね
まあ それは 未来に対する
期待というか 希望というか
もしかすると 夢かもしれません
でも私は それを育てることに
とても楽しみを感じています
今もそうです
で それ以外に 私は子供のときから
とても好奇心の旺盛な子どもでした
いろいろな新しいことに
興味を持っていたのですけども
特に外国という所に対して
人一倍 関心を持ち
憧れを持っていました
そんな私が 40代の半ばに
なったころでしょうか
ま 日本もそれまでは
普通の人が 海外に渡航することは
許されていなかったんですけども
私たち普通の人も 旅行に行っていいと
いうことになったのです
「やったー！」と思って 私は
限られた休暇をやりくりして
ヨーロッパやオセアニアに
ひとりで 旅をしてまいりました
もちろん それは感動の毎日でした
そんなあるときミュンヘンで知り合った
アメリカ人の牧師さんに
「あんたは アメリカというのを
見たほうがいい
そうだ コネチカットの
私の牧師館に来なさい
そして ファミリーステイをして
そこから アメリカを見なさい」と言われて
アメリカに行きました
皆さん とても良くして下さったんですけども
私はとにかく 片言の英語しか
喋れないので
もっともっと 色々交流したかったのに
とても不満足でした
というのは 私の知りたいようなことは
なかなか英語で表現できなかったのです
それは ホテルの予約をするというときに
使うような英語では 済まされなかったのです
「もっと英語の勉強をしたい！」
そのとき そう思いました
そして 私は旅行をすると
皆さんと同じように
美しい風景を楽しんだり
町の佇まいを見て
感心したりする それ以上に
「そこに住んでいる人はどんな人かしら？」
と想像してしまうのです
「あそこでコーヒーを飲んで
いらっしゃる方は 私と同年代だわ
あの人は戦時中 どんな少女時代を
送ったのかしら？」
「この大きな牧場のオーナーは
今 何を考えていらっしゃるのかしら？」
そんなことが 次から次へと
浮かんでくるのでした
しかし 私にとっての英語への道は
とっても遠いのでした
といいますのは
私たちが戦争中というのは
皆さんが 想像もつかないような
時代だったんですね
[日本では] 戦争中は英語を使うことが
禁止されていたのです
ですから 野球の審判もですね
「ワンストライク ツーボール」
と言ったら 叱られるんです
「良し１本 駄目２本」
と言わなければならなかった
そんな時代だったんです
ですから なかなか
英語とは縁がなかった
高校を卒業してから勤めた銀行でも
海外とは関係のない仕事を続けていました
で 仕事をリタイアして
介護も終わって
やっと少し
自分の時間が持てたとき
私はもう 70になっていました
「だめだわ もうこんな歳になったら
とてもだめ
だって どんどん記憶力が
低下していくでしょう？
語学が一番だめよね」
なんて言って諦めかけていました
そんなとき
まったくどういうわけか
さっきお話しいただいた
TEDxの2014に
スピーカーとして出させて頂いたんです
「いったい スピーカーって
どんなもの？」
私はとても 心細かったんですけども
周りの方の温かいサポートと
それから 観客の方の拍手と声援で
私はなんとか終わりまで
こぎつけたんです
ホッとしました
だから 英語を学んでいきたい
ということは
またそこでも［思いました］
で そのとき 考えたんです
私がエクセルアートを考えたっていうのは
Excelの苦手なシニアの女性のために
少し女性とExcelを近づけるために
考えたのが エクセルアート
それだったら 英語だって
シニアに もうちょっと近づける
何かが あるんじゃないかしらと思って
考えていたんですね
シニアはシニアなりのやり方があって
そしたら 母の介護を
していたときのことを思い出しました
もちろん 歳相応に記憶力は
低下していきますけども
昔から知っていた言葉というのは
意外と覚えてるんのですね
たとえそれがカタカナ語でも
外来語でも同じだったのです
考えてみたら 私が普段
使っている言葉にも
カタカナ語や外来語がいっぱいあります
コンピューター関係なんて
そっちの方が 多いですよね
そうだ これを英語の木の
根っこに持って来れば
いいんじゃないかしらと思ったんです
それで たとえば
それを例にとって言いますと
お婆ちゃんはですね
アパートとかデパートという言葉を
よく知ってました
アパート、デパートの
共通しているところは"Part"
じゃ 今度は
"Part"というのを根っこにして
それを持って海外旅行したらどうかしら
ということで
私は出かけて行ったのでした
そして まず
"Part"というのは
「分かれる」とか「離れる」とか
そういう意味ですよね？
で まず空港に行ったら
"Departure Gate"ってのが
あったんです
ここにも"Part"という字が
入っていました
「わぁ すごい！」と思っちゃいました
それから"Part-time Job"とか
"Participate"とか
"Particular"とか
だんだん 少しずつ難しい言葉にも
手が出るようになりました
そして あるときイタリアに行ったら
そこのガイドさんが
「このあたりはパルチザンが
たくさんいたところなんですよ」
「パルチザン？ パーティザン？
あれ？これも"Part"と
関係があるんじゃない？
そうよね だってこれ
別働隊の意味ですもんね」と思いました
そして今度は ドイツに行って
新聞の大きな見出しに
「パータイ」と出てたんですね
「あれ？ これって パーティのこと
じゃないかしら？」と思いました
私のその英語の木には
英語だけではなくて
ヨーロッパ語の実までなるように
なったのです
素晴らしいです
私は感動しました
それから
でも そんなことはさておき
私の記憶力は 本当に
おぼつかないものでした
で 私の歳になると
皆さんも お父様お母様か お爺様お婆様に
聞いていて頂くと分かるんですが
口のここまで出てる言葉が出てこない
っていうことが時々あるんです
今こうやって お話していても
あるんですけど
そういうときは
とてもいらいらします
でもそんなとき
どうするかといいますと
私はコンピューターに頼むんです
コンピューターにですね
[ Please speak ]
フレンチ、デザート、 ふわふわ
これが 出るでしょうか
あぁ 出ましたね
ここにですね「スフレ」って名前が
出てきたんです
そうして
「あなたの食べたいのはこれでしょ？」
って画像まで出てきたんです
素晴らしいです
コンピューターにできることは
コンピューターにお願いすればいいんです
でも こういうのが 英語ではなくて
他の分野でも何か
年寄りだけが持っている
シニアの特性を活かした勉強方法というのが
今後 考えられたらいいなと思いました
そうすれば シニアだからって
がっかりすることはないんです
もしかすると
「80代では遅い」ではなくて
「80代は まだ間に合う」
「80代は育ち盛り 伸び盛り」
になるかもわからないです
まあ それはちょっと
楽観的すぎるかも わからないですけども
ただ それはいいんです
しかし私はそれと同じだけの
コンピューターで 答えてくれるような
言葉だけではなくて
もう１つ大事なものが
あると思ったんです
それは 感性とか情緒とか
感動とかいう世界です
この気持ちの共有というのは
コンピューターの翻訳エンジンでは
ちょっと難しいのです
でも 私たち年をとっても
寝たきりになっても
認知力がだんだん低下して
物忘れが激しくなっても
感情とか 感動とかいうものは
結構 意外とみずみずしく残ってるんです
寂しい、やるせないとかいうこと
わくわくする感動
何かを発見したときの喜びは
たくさんあるんですね
ですから これは今までどおりに
大事にしていきたい
そんなふうに 考えています
私はICTエヴァンジェリストを
志しています
それは 情報の力で
シニアがより一層楽しい
内容のあるシニアライフを
送れるから と思ったんですけども
シニアの人と一緒に
こういう英語の木を植えて
英語にも目覚めて
そうすれば もっと広い世界が 私たちの
前に開けるのではないかと思います
さらに 21世紀のこれから起こる
色々なことも
もしも 受け入れられる好奇心と
タフなマインドがあれば
きっと 21世紀は素晴らしい
と言いますのは 私たち
いわゆる「おばあちゃんの知恵」
というのを 持っています
「おばあちゃんの知恵」というのは
今まで培ってきた「経験」に「学び」
それがじっくり熟成されてできたものが
「おばあちゃんの知恵」です
それと豊かな感性、情感
そういうものがある
シニアが活躍すれば
少子高齢化の日本も すごい人材を
たくさん抱えることになると思います
それで私は 私の生きている間に
できないことは
次の世代に引き継いでいきたいと思います
ですから 私は自分の育てている木に
毎晩水をやると同時に
他の皆さんにも 木を植えることを
お勧めしようと 思っているのです
そして 木がどんどん増えていけば
やがては 森になります
その森が いくつもいくつもできて
海外にも 森ができれば
地球は 緑に囲まれた惑星になります
素晴らしいことです
でも それには 木に水をやって
育てていかなければいけないのです
ですから 私は今日もこれから
もしも 私が明日死んじゃうと
いうことが わかっていても
私は自分の木に水をやって
こうやって 水をやりながら
慈しんでいきたいと思います
と言いますのも
それが 次の世代を育てるからです
（英語）だから たとえ
（英語）明日死ぬと
わかっていたとしても
（英語）私は今日も
自分のどの木にも
（英語）水をやることでしょう
（英語）皆さん ありがとう
（拍手）